we've covered conspiracies
conspiratorial thinking and conspiracism
on the David Pakman show over the years
today
our deep dive into the origins not the
oranges you know what I'm talking about
the origins of conspiratorial thinking
how it works how people get into and out
of conspiratorial thinking and
particular theories and much more with
both interviews and coverage of
conspiracy from over the last several
years let's get right into it the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
six one seven eight three zero 4750
here's something risky we're going to
take our next call from country code 49
I have no [ __ ] no clue what country code
49 is but who's where is country code 49
and who is this
is between calling from Germany can you
understand me well we can understand you
find Daniel go ahead perfect okay so my
question isn't about American politics I
hope that's okay well let's see what the
question is and then we'll evaluate the
question is maybe you've noticed that
Republican guy Paul Newlin posting this
list on Twitter of Jews who attack him
on this statement they have not seen
that list of Jews now okay so something
that I noticed recently is in the wake
of the odd right that this rhetoric of
you know Jews controlling the media and
all that stuff it's becoming even more
prominent than getting into the
mainstream and together with that
there's also things like Holocaust
denial or that just ridiculous stuff um
what is your opinion on engaging this
sort of stuff is it what even trying to
debunk it or would you just try to
ignore it no I I think it's it's tough
to go head-to-head and try and debunk
that stuff so I think a better general
practice is not to get involved I do
think it's important you know big
picture if if stereotypes are sort of
perpetrated never with any opposition it
can be problematic because it can appear
to legitimize those hey listen people
are saying this over and over again
nobody's refuting it so maybe there is
something to it so I think big picture
it's important to make clear that those
types of stereotypes and prejudices are
considered invalid and discriminatory
but at sort of the individual level it's
sort of a personal choice whether you
want to get into like a
point-counterpoint debate about Jews
control the media for example and if
you're going to engage I think it's like
the Jews controlling media is a good
example for us to talk about one
approach would be to try to give counter
examples of how Jews don't control media
or something like that but that's never
going to
Vince a conspiracy theorist I think a
better a protest to say listen whether
or not for historical reasons Jew and
Jewish individuals might be
over-represented in certain industries
relative to their population the idea of
a conspiracy to control and working in
concert is absolutely not backed by
evidence and sort of picking it apart
that way rather than trying to provide
examples of a Christian who's in media
you know I think that that the latter is
not nearly as effective I see ok well
then thanks for answering my question
all right appreciate it Daniel great to
hear from Germany very Heidi I got to
ask how do you square that viewpoint
with your choice to interview Richard
Spencer other racist and anti-semite
this is a program I mean they're the
leaders of these causes leaders of the
causes is different but also this is a
program where this it's sort of what
we're doing we're exploring and exposing
these ideas and I challenge my sense was
that the caller was asking more on sort
of like a in a day-to-day mundane way or
something like Joe down the street sure
Joe Nazi down the street or whatever you
want to call him a Shepard Smith is
sometimes the lone single I guess I
would call him voice of reason on Fox
News and it must be pretty tough for him
right being the only one there who ever
is even remotely connected to the real
world in any case Fox News has been at
the forefront along with other
right-wing media outlets pushing this
bogus Hillary Clinton uranium one
conspiracy theory and every once in a
while like on live calls or during a
YouTube live stream someone will ask me
David why aren't you covering the
blockbuster Hillary Clinton uranium one
story and I'm not covering it because
it's a bogus debunked conspiracy theory
widely debunked and there are endless
important issues and breaking news to
discuss every single day however I do
want to talk about it today because
something very interesting happened on
Fox News Shepard Smith took six minutes
and destroyed the Hillary Clinton
uranium one conspiracy theory which is
particularly interesting because Fox
News has been one of the primary
purveyors of that conspiracy theory and
the
it came up on fox news is because
yesterday Jeff Sessions Trump's attorney
general again testified and he was
questioned by Democrats mostly about
possible and at this point pretty clear
lies and Miss statements and and
deception around contacts between the
Trump campaign and Russia however there
were some Republicans who questioned
Jeff Sessions yesterday who had no
interest whatsoever in asking him about
the pressing matters which is have you
perjured yourself and how many times
have you lied under oath they wanted to
talk about other stuff including but not
limited to the Hillary Clinton uranium
one conspiracy theory so that caused
Shepard Smith to decide to debunk the
entire thing he seems to have had enough
he said so on fox news here's a little
bit of Shepard Smith at least trying to
set the record straight to what is
probably not a particularly receptive
audience to be to being talked out of a
Hillary Clinton conspiracy theory here's
Shep now here's the accusation nine
people involved in the deal made
donations to the Clinton Foundation
totaling more than 140 million dollars
in exchange Secretary of State Clinton
approved the sale to the Russians a quid
pro quo the accusation first made by
Peter Schweitzer the senior editor at
large of the website
Breitbart in his 2015 book Clinton cash
the next year candidate Donald Trump
cited the accusation as an example of
Clinton corruption Hillary Clinton State
Department approved the transfer of 20%
of America's uranium holdings to Russia
while nine investors in the deal
funneled 145 million dollars to the
Clinton Foundation that statement is
inaccurate in a number of ways first the
Clinton State Department had no power to
veto or approve that transaction it
could do neither so Shep went on like
this for a full six minutes picking
apart every aspect of this conspiracy
theory I won't play the full six minutes
for you you can probably find it online
if you want you
definitely find it online if you want
but if you already understand that this
is a debunk conspiracy theory you
probably have no need for the full six
minutes eventually Shep Smith got to his
conclusion with this thing even so the
accusation is predicated on the charge
that Secretary Clinton approved the sale
she did not a committee of nine
evaluated the sale the president
approved the sale the Nuclear Regulatory
Commission and others had to offer
permits and none of the uranium was
exported for use by the u.s. to Russia
that is uranium one this was actually a
really really good explanation a
debunking of the entire story not where
we would normally expect to see such a
detailed debunking of a right-wing
conspiracy theory and as I was watching
this I was just imagining the core fox
news audience totally confused wondering
what on earth is happening on Fox News
and there's this really funny and also
kind of disturbing funny maybe it's not
the right word thing that happens when
but you see Shep Smith just talking
sense on fox news
there are many homophobic right-wingers
who understand you can't just go around
calling people [ __ ] these days that
generally speaking sexual orientation
even if you think it's wrong to be gay
lesbian whatever that you don't want to
just publicly slam people for it with
homophobic terms because it's in most of
the country now not widely accepted but
you go and look at online forums where
they are discussing this clip or other
stories where Shep Smith has sort of
departed from the right wing talking
points all you see are comments like
this guy's a [ __ ] Shep is gay he can't be
trusted what do you expect from the gay
guy on Fox News and you and I realized
that being gay has no bearing whatsoever
on whether you can accurately report on
a hypothetical uranium sale but these
right-wingers see something they don't
like on fox news and they revert
immediately to just homophobic slurs
it's like they can't control each other
if only sober factual explanations
actually changed Trumpets minds but the
Fox fans are furious
with Shepard Smith I was looking at some
tweets earlier today and people are just
losing their minds over this guy you
need to get that hack Shepard Smith out
of Fox he just made excuses for crooked
Hillary and is clearly a double agent
hey Shep Hillary took the hundred and
forty five million regardless of when it
was sent pay-for-play
you goof another tweet slamming Shepard
Smith I normally don't tune into chefs
hour on Fox can't stand his bias but
today while surfing channels he caught
my interest in three minutes he argued
Hillary's defense how she had nothing to
do with uranium won and how Trump had
lied about it he has to go turning on
Shep very quickly and what's really
funny is if you're watching TV with us
right now I have on screen a still shot
from the Sean Hannity program on the one
hand you've got Shep Smith completely
debunking uranium one and then on the
Sean Hannity program you have something
like look like it like out of the
Beautiful Mind the story the film with
Russell Crowe it's this crazy flowchart
of conspiracy that was taking place on
the exact same channel where Shepard
Smith completely debunked the story and
then on Laura Ingraham Fox News's newest
host she was all over the Hillary
uranium one thing how stupid does it
make the network look when in the
afternoon Shep Smith completely and
totally debunked the conspiracy theory
and then Sean Hannity and Laura Ingraham
just go back to talking about the
conspiracy theory like the debunking
never happened and the truth is that for
the trumpets and for the Fox and users
who didn't see Shep Smith's debunking
it's like it didn't happen and my only
question is how does Shep Smith get away
with this and I had a few thoughts about
it one possibility
may be Shep Smith's contract protects
him and he can say whatever he wants and
he can't be fired I don't know I don't
know what his contract looks like
another option is that Fox News has sort
of calculated they say listen way more
people watch the evening stuff than Fox
News during the day so let's let Shep
say whatever the hell he wants
and then few people will see that
everybody will see the Hannity stuff and
Ingram stuff and then we can claim that
our network is a an incubator of a
variety of opinions because we're
allowing Shep Smith to do this stuff I
don't know the answer okay I don't know
why it is that Shep Smith is allowed to
do this stuff year after year maybe it's
because he doesn't do that much of it
it's like every six months we talk about
him it's unclear but a very good job
done by Shep here debunking this
conspiracy theory send me your thoughts
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman we'll be back
after this the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com we have a fantastic long form
deep type dive for you today on
conspiracy theories and what makes this
extra special is that it's a crossover
episode with Natanz notes the relatively
new youtube channel headed up by former
TV director on the david pakman show and
my little brother 'not on pakman he is
voicing over and walking us through
conspiracy theories and conspiratorial
thinking on today's deep dive let's get
right into it
how do conspiracy theories work
conspiracy theories and conspiratorial
thinking are around us all the time from
eccentric friends who question whether
we landed on the moon to the fact that a
majority of Americans believe that Lee
Harvey Oswald wasn't the only person
involved in the JFK assassination let's
take a look at how conspiracy theories
work before we begin we should clarify
the difference between a conspiracy
theory and a conspiracy a conspiracy is
a fact about the world a situation for
which there's good evidence that two or
more people worked together conspired to
commit an illegal or immoral act a
conspiracy theory on the other hand is
an allegation or claim that an event was
caused by a conspiracy a conspiracy is
something that's known as a result of
investigating the causes of an event a
conspiracy theory on the other hand is
the result of rejecting the evidence
that explains an event actual
conspiracies include the plot of Roman
senators to assassinate Julius Caesar
the 1953 Iranian coup that overthrew the
democratically elected prime minister
orchestrated by the US and the UK the
Watergate break-in and any time two or
more people get together to rob a bank
let's look at five common
characteristics of conspiracy theories
first the presupposition that nothing
ever happens by accident that chaos or
randomness does not end
cannot explain significant world and
historical events most conspiracy
theorists would accept that any one of
us could get hit by a car while crossing
a street due to completely accidental or
random causes like the driver having the
Sun in their eyes for three straight
seconds right as you cross the street in
front of them but the conspiratorial
world view is that events of major
significance at least significance to
humans never occur this way more on why
this is later
second the idea of a small group of
people in power pulling the puppet
strings behind the scenes a good example
of this I think is the old anti-semitic
canard of Jewish control the core here
is that there's a cabal of Jews
controlling events in secret for their
own benefit so it's been said that Jews
controlled the media the Federal Reserve
Wall Street Hollywood that they were
behind historical Wars and revolutions
and even that they seek world domination
the most influential expression of these
ideas is the protocols of the Elders of
Zion the text was a hoax plagiarized
from earlier sources first published in
Russia in 1903 and purported to be the
minutes of a meeting of Jewish leaders
at the end of the 19th century
conspiring together to take over the
world it's been debunked many times but
its popularity and influence continues
to be significant Henry Ford funded the
printing of 500,000 copies that were
distributed in the u.s. in the 1920s and
it was cited in Hitler's Mein Kampf and
in Nazi propaganda more recently it was
referenced in Hollis's charter and
continues to be read in multiple
languages and this is a feature of most
conspiracy theories that a small and
powerful group supposedly the Jews in
this particular case have orchestrated a
big nefarious scheme behind closed doors
a third common trait of conspiracy
theories is that official stories are
considered to be propaganda used by
those in power to brainwash most of the
general public think about for example
the Warren Commission report an 888 page
document submitted to President Lyndon
in September 1964 concluding that Lee
Harvey Oswald acted entirely alone in
the assassination of JFK attacking the
Warren Commission and it's report is a
key feature of JFK assassination
conspiracy theories one of the main
points is the single Bullet theory often
ridiculed and called the quote Magic
Bullet theory which the report used to
explain how one of the three bullets
fired by Oswald hit Kennedy's neck and
Texas Governor John Connally 's chest
wrist and thigh the supposed
implausibility of the same bullet
behaving this way is commonly cited and
was even the focus of a key scene in
Oliver Stone's JFK and a parody scene in
an episode of Seinfeld now to any of you
wondering whether only magic could
explain what this bullet did it's been
modeled and analyzed many times and
found to be completely consistent with
the laws of physics fourth skepticism
now this is actually pretty interesting
conspiracy theories often appeal to our
usual sense of skepticism but take it to
an irrational extreme they take
advantage of the fact that it's easy to
sow doubt in us simply by asking
questions that appear to expose
inconsistencies in official accounts of
events consider nasa's footage of the
Apollo 11 moon landing conspiracy loved
to point out the appearance of a waving
American flag as the pole is being fixed
into position by the astronauts they say
there's no wind on the moon so how could
the flag possibly wave now this is a
perfectly reasonable question and of
course there's also a perfectly
reasonable answer while the astronauts
place the flag on the ground it vibrated
the flagpole and flag and the inertia in
the vacuum of space led to some movement
of the flag that looked to us like
waving also the astronauts accidentally
bent the horizontal rods holding the
flag in place several times which
created the appearance of a rippling
flag in the still photographs lastly and
very importantly is the unfalsifiable
'ti of conspiracy theories if you
disprove any specific point or argument
made by conspiracy theorists they either
claim that your quote evidence is
fake and/or part of the official
propaganda story or they accept it and
immediately move on to the next point so
to take the moon-landing example if you
explain why the flag appeared to be
waving a conspiracist might say yeah
sure but what about the fact that
there's no blast crater when the lunar
module landed or if you point to an
aspect of the photos that disproves
their point they answer those images
were doctored by NASA in this way
confirmation bias causes conspiracy
theorists to take any evidence you throw
at them any evidence they encounter even
evidence which contradicts their
theories and incorporate it as further
proof of their conclusion so why is it
that some people buy into conspiracy
theories we live in a world that is in
many ways full of complexity and chaos
terrible things happen for no good
reason scientific explanations can seem
completely counterintuitive and an event
that changes history can occur by
complete accident it's difficult for a
lot of people to accept that a lot of
what happens in the world is by
coincidence or through causes outside of
our control some of these people turn to
conspiracy theories because they provide
reassurance that what's happening in
their lives or the things that we see on
the news have identifiable
incomprehensible causes there's been a
lot of research especially over the past
15 years aimed at understanding the
psychology of those who believe in
conspiracy theories conspiratorial
belief it turns out correlates with
certain personality traits such as
intellectual curiosity a strong
imagination cynicism toward politics and
distrust of authority psychological
studies have found that belief in
conspiracy theories also tends to
correlate with belief in creationism the
paranormal superstitions and New Age
beliefs conspiracism has also been tied
to a tendency to see patterns where
there are none a 20-18 study by
psychologist Joshua heart gave cognitive
tests to over 1,200 American adults and
also asked them questions about what
they thought about statements like quote
the power held by heads of state is
second to the
of small unknown groups who really
control world politics and quote groups
of scientists manipulate fabricate or
suppress evidence in order to deceive
the public those who agreed with the
conspiratorial statements were much more
likely to identify non-existent patterns
when shown randomized visual images and
they were more likely to interpret
nonsensical statements as profound so on
portions of the test that had nothing to
do with politics or conspiracies the
conspiracists tended to attribute
meaning and intention where non
conspiracists did not some researchers
have also suggested that conspiratorial
thinkers suffer from what's known as
proportionality bias in other words when
someone has trouble believing that an
event with large scale consequences can
have a small scale cause for example
that a lone gunman would assassinate JFK
that someone as famous as Princess Diana
could have been killed by a simple car
accident or that a mere group of 19
terrorists could create the devastation
of 9/11 assuming that these were all
high-level government conspiracies would
maintain the proportionality between the
causes and the consequences and it's an
understandable impulse but of course
significant events like these often do
have spontaneous small-scale causes
believing in conspiracy theories also
provides an insider sense of being in
the no conspiracy theorists and their
followers form groups that know quote
what really happened and how things
really are just think of all the
conspiracy theorists who go around Kong
people shills or sheep so although we
can understand and maybe even empathize
with what drives people to believe in
conspiracy theories it would be a
mistake to discount the dangerous
real-life consequences of believing in
them belief in conspiracy theories has
led to physical violence and terrorism
such as the 1995 Oklahoma City bombing
many people who subscribe to conspiracy
theories have a misplaced distrust or
animosity toward institutions that in
reality are beneficial to society and in
some cases they can even develop a
hatred toward entire groups of people
conspiracy theories about vaccines and
have led people to not vaccinate their
children against deadly diseases and
surveys have shown that people who
believe climate change to be a hoax are
far less willing to reduce their carbon
footprint the more complex a problem is
the more complex the solution tends to
be so some people find comfort in
falsely asserting problems to be more
simple than they actually are because it
would mean that the solution is simple
if the MMR vaccine causes autism and the
medical community is ignorant about it
then the solution is simple don't trust
the medical community and don't use
vaccines it's much less palatable to
consider that autism has complicated
genetic causes that aren't yet fully
understood leaving us for the time being
with no easy answers of course you might
be watching and thinking to yourself
sometimes powerful people do conspire
sometimes the public is being lied to by
the powers that be well there's a
difference between a healthy skepticism
and habitually getting caught up in
conspiracy theories one method you might
use to tell the difference is to
consider how implausible it would be for
a huge number of conspirators to keep
everything a secret Benjamin Franklin
once wrote quote three may keep a secret
if two of them are dead physicist Robert
David Grimes has developed a
statistically rigorous formula to
determine how long it would take for a
conspiracy to be exposed based on the
number of people that must have been
involved basically the more people
involved in the conspiracy the faster a
leak would have to emerge Grimes
calculated that the supposed
moon-landing hoax would require the
involvement of about four hundred and
eleven thousand people and would be
exposed within three point six eight
years a hoax about manmade global
warming would involve about four hundred
and five thousand people and would be
exposed within 3.7 years so yes some
conspiracies are real but we often find
out about them through people leaking
information and we need to be reasonable
about how improbable it would be for
there to be no leaks whatsoever over an
extended period of time from a supposed
conspiracy that involves a great number
of people another method for fine
the line between rational skepticism and
misguided conspiracism is to employ a
critical thinking principle known as
Occam's razor Occam's razor essentially
suggests that all things being equal we
should favor explanations that require
the fewest assumptions if we already
have a reasonable explanation for why
something happened there's no need to
invoke additional speculation if your
dog has a history of digging through
your garbage and you come home and find
your trashcan flipped over it's
unreasonable to start hypothesizing
about who broke into your house to tip
over your trashcan barring some specific
evidence to point you in that direction
we can also identify improbable
conspiracy theories by recognizing when
a conspiracy theorist is frequently and
fallaciously appealing to vagueness they
try to explain something complex by
giving reasons that are even more
complex and nebulous leaving endlessly
branching explanations without ever
arriving at hard facts or evidence
skepticism deals with facts proving
facts describing facts questioning facts
while conspiracy theories are generally
more concerned with attributing motives
and analyzing an event in terms of its
meaning and significance and how it fits
into a larger narrative as humans
looking for patterns is in our very
nature but it's also possible to overdo
it and connect dots that have no
business being connected and like I
talked about there are studies pointing
to the notion that there might even be
broader personality traits at play that
cause people to go down this road we
have to acknowledge that we live in an
unpredictable world filled with
randomness coincidences and accidents
that can have hugely profound
consequences and jumping to
unsubstantiated conclusions about
conspiracies is almost never gonna get
us closer to understanding how things
really work or solving our problems
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome back to the david
pakman show it's great to welcome to the
program today rent Nancy rosenbloom who
is a Harvard University Department of
Government professor emeritus who wrote
the book a lot of people are saying
co-written with Russell Muirhead
Nancy so great to have you on the
program I'm delighted to be with you
David so I think an interesting place to
start would be we talked a lot about
conspiracy theories conspiratorial
thinking on the program we've looked at
some of the psychological mechanisms
that impact people getting into this
type of thinking but one thing we've not
discussed so much is whether from a sort
of objective empirical point point of
view conspiratorial type thinking is
increasing in society so let's maybe
start there do we have any strong
evidence one way or the other about
whether in general this type of thought
is more prevalent today than it has been
in the past I don't think we have more
evidence of its prevalence I think we
can say two things with with some
confidence one is that the spread of
conspiracy thinking probably has
increased because of the Internet it's
costless and speedy to spread these
kinds of rumors or claims and that gives
us a reason it's hard to count on the
Internet as you probably know but it
gives us reason to think that more
people are at least exposed to these
things
whether or not they're true believers I
think the other thing I can say with
confidence because it's the theme of my
book is that there is a new kind of
conspiracy thinking out there today and
it's not conspiracy theory as we
understand it it's conspiracism without
the theory the two have become decoupled
and this really is a new
and malignant phenomenon in politics
it's brought conspiracy thinking in from
the fringe right into the White House
and the halls of power and it has I
think a different significance and
different effect than classic conspiracy
theory well so can we first define the
difference what would be and maybe
examples would be good when we talk
about conspiracy theorizing versus
conspiracism what what is the
distinction between the two well the
conspiracy theory is a theory we should
take that part of the phrase seriously
that is it's offering an explanation of
things and conspiracy theories theorists
do a lot of rigorous work they collect
the dots they amass evidence they find
patterns in this evidence they develop a
grand narrative and sometimes these
conspiracy theories are actually true
and sometimes they're completely
fantastic and unwarranted and often
they're a vexing mix of the two but in
any case these people are like
researchers they are making an argument
based on evidence and they want you to
think that this argument is true that
the unintelligible the previously
unintelligible has been made
intelligible by their findings and that
the unbelievable has been made
believable so for example a conspiracy
theorist has an account of the real
assassination of John F Kennedy right or
a conspiracy theory about the real
sources of the 9/11 attack that it
wasn't nineteen men operating out of the
remote quarters of Afghanistan it was
the US government or drones or whatever
it was so that's a conspiracy theory
it's an explanation and in a way
conspiracy theorists reason the same way
we all reason when we want to make an
argument about something that's
happening in the world the new
conspiracism really is entirely
different it's conspiracy without theory
and it doesn't attempt to clean play
explain anything there are no dots there
are no patterns is no evidence there's
no argument instead what you have is a
bare assertion the election is rude for
example or the Mulla report is an
attempt at a coup d'etat so it's bare
assertion sometimes it takes the form
I'm just asking questions you know what
I know is bad enough people would say
about the birth or conspiracy what I
know is bad enough but I'm just asking
questions what I really want is to know
a lot more or they or they take it takes
the form of a kind of attribution like
us some agent of government is plotting
something it's an insidious plot it's
clearly ominous it's something worse
than sort of partisan bias or
self-interest but there's no explanation
of who or why or for what purpose so
it's conspiracies and without without
the explanation and there's a way in
which this conspiracism without the
explanation is very powerful yeah well I
was going to ask is one more pernicious
than the other or dangerous than the
other because you you might imagine that
with the particular conspiracy theory
you can at least attempt to take the
theory head-on present you know a
contradictory narrative ask for that
evidence ask what might change your mind
about this particular theory it seems
that with conspiracism more generally it
could be more difficult to disabuse
someone of those beliefs I think that
that's exactly exactly right but I made
the point earlier the conspiracy theory
reasons the way we reason these kinds of
bare assertions like the election is
rigged are completely disorienting
they're disorienting and unnerving
because they um they they completely
change the what it means for us to know
something because they come without
argument they come just with insistence
and when we can't when and so it changes
as I say what it means to know something
and it's very hard to answer it
the other thing that makes it much more
dangerous of course is that it's coming
from the Office of the President or from
elected representatives or from from
governor's and so on and of course from
conspiracy entrepreneurs who spread it
and there's a third thing that makes it
I think more potent than conspiracy
theory and then that it uses the intern
in a different way conspiracy theorists
use the internet to find their dots and
their evidence right architects and
engineers for 9/11 truth look up the the
escalating temperature of jet fuels for
example or the capacities of drones
whereas the new conspiracists used the
Internet really very differently to
spread their ideas and when you make a
bare assertion it's easy to spread right
you can do it in two hundred and eighty
characters easily you're not offering an
explanation and they use assent to this
theory as as validation what validates
it is not the argument what validates it
is a lot of people are saying and that's
the title of the book so and you can in
a sense count the number of retweets or
likes or shares and so you can say a lot
of people are saying that the Obama
administration tapped the phones of
Trump Tower during the campaign yeah my
sense when I talk to conspiracy
theorists is that they do care and are
genuinely invested in the truth or
falsity of what their assertions are
exactly how how does that compare to
conspiracism because with some of these
conspiracists ideas I am less convinced
that those espousing the ideas are
actually invested in the truth but
rather are invested merely in the spread
of the of the general notion for their
benefit I think that that's very
perceptive of you David and here's
here's how I understand it um when the
president for example makes conspiracist
claim that the Justice Department is
planning a coup the people who follow
him who are sent to it who spread it who
repeated don't necessarily think that
all of the elements or all of the facts
have to be true they think that they are
the phrase that we use is that this
claim is true enough that is it fits
with their political hostilities and
political animosities and political
connections so that the story is true
enough if you think that Hillary Clinton
is
evil and does horrible things and lies
about it then the pizza gay conspiracy
which says that she's running a child
sex trafficking ring out of the basement
of a pizza parlor in Northwest
Washington DC they don't necessarily
have to believe that if all of those
facts are true what they believe is it's
true enough and let me read you because
this confirms your hypothesis here let
me read you a couple of quotes about
what true enough really sounds like so a
Republican representative in Congress
was asked about the allegation that the
Democratic Party had actually conspired
to create that clash between white
nationalists and protesters in
Charlottesville in 1917 and that
representative said I'm not saying it's
true but I'm saying it's completely
plausible
another example when Sarah Huckabee
Sanders was asked about Trump's tweet of
a video that falsely purported to show a
Muslim immigrant assaulting someone she
said whether it's a real video the
threat is real and this is the point
that is true enough so probably there
were some believers who think every
element of something like pizza gate is
true and in fact an armed gunman went to
the pizza parlor and shot up the place
because he went to rescue the children
but most I think do not I think that
this new conspiracism and the assent to
it and the validation through tweeting
and liking and affirming and so on is a
sort of form of political participation
yeah well I was going to say that
there's this there's this
rationalization that often exists which
is it's less important whether this is
specifically true because belief in this
serves is sort of a means to an end even
if this particular assertion is not true
and I think that that's how a lot of
conspiracists rationalize continuing to
spread stuff that even they question the
truth of I think that's right and so
then the question becomes why is this so
dangerous what's happening I mean we
could look back and say it's absurd we
could say it's as new in sort of a
malignant form of political expression
but we haven't gotten that why it's
really dangerous why we should care
about it
and why I think it's one of the most
prominent and unders under assessed
elements of American politics today the
spread of conspiracism and I think that
what it does besides disorienting us is
to deal Ajith Amin foundational
democratic institutions and are the most
obvious is all kinds of knowledge
producing institutions have been
diligent amazed by these conspiracists
claims the most obvious and publicized
is fake news big news doesn't just say
that they're erroneous or making a
partisan stories fake news really says
that there's a conspiracy in the
mainstream media to denigrate the
administration and that it's that the
newscasters or enemies of the people but
that's just the most obvious every time
when Trump says for example that he had
the biggest inaugural crowd in history
and then the National Park Service
photograph showed that it was a modest
crowd what did he do he said that the
that the National Park Service doctored
the photographs this is a conspiracists
claim and it undermines the meaning and
the value and the authority of the
National Park Service and the same thing
is true when he attacks the FBI or
National Intelligence Estimates when the
National Intelligence director Dan coats
issued his annual threat assessment and
said the climate changed had become a
security threat for a variety of reasons
the administration said he should go
back to school what is the National
Intelligence director now so we have
this cumulative D legitimation of all
kinds of knowledge producing
institutions and we need them because
you cannot make political decisions and
policy decisions without some confidence
that facts matter and conspiracism is a
better more permanent more powerful I
think way of dealing debating these
institutions and the facts that they
assess then lies
Trump's lies come and go for example
they are fact-checked or they're not but
they're hard to keep up with I think the
New York Times said something like
10,000 recently yeah his conspiracies
play
and the ones that are supported by his
followers and by many Republicans today
they're pretty permanent the same ones
go on and on
they have traction he comes back to them
again and again and they do this D
legitimation Nancy in the limited time
we have left I'd love to just briefly
hear what are the techniques if there
are any that you have found to be
effective in getting people away from
conspiracists beliefs and a sort of
conspiracies framework well to some
extent it's the same as combating lies I
think there's a kind of fact-checking
that can go on I would insist that you
will never get at the people who are
supporting Trump and other conspiracies
claims for political reasons right this
is a bit of entrenched polarization so
the question is can you immunize or give
some confidence to the rest of the
public who really gets sort of
disoriented by these wacky claims and
who I think turn off politically and
it's really justice I think a matter of
giving people confidence in their common
sense because that's what these
conspiracies claims do they D legitimate
institutions a diligent make political
parties and political opposition but
they do it in a way that offends common
sense that's why we're so disoriented by
it all and I think some confidence and
common sense that comes about by
speaking truth to conspiracism is the
best thing we can do we've been speaking
with Nancy rosenbloom Harvard University
Department of Government professor
emeritus wrote the book a lot of people
are saying co-written of course with
Russell Muirhead
Nancy such a pleasure having you on I
appreciate it and you were a great
question David thank you the david
pakman show at david pakman
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let's go to our next caller
from the 505 area code caller from 505
go ahead
hey David this is John from New Mexico
hey I just had a question if you could
have any conspiracy theory or
quote-unquote conspiracy theory be
completely revealed and just out there
so it's no longer in question and some
examples would be something like 9/11 or
climate change or just the the
corruption of politics you know money in
politics or schools or investigation let
me see if I understand with that let me
see if I understand you're saying if I
could pick a conspiracy theory and have
it ravit have it be true which one would
it be not necessarily be true but just
look have it out there so it's no longer
conspiracy because for example some you
know Republicans think that climate
change is a ospc
yeah you see what I mean so you're
saying like some people think 9/11 was
an inside job it wouldn't be that do I
want 9/11 to be proven as true but just
if we could definitively prove that 9/11
wasn't an inside job like would that be
the one that I would write I think it
would be climate change because right
now it's having the moat it's going to
have the most long-term impact on us I
think that that would be that would be
it right in a thousand years I don't
know how much it will matter whether it
was ultimately debunked that 9/11 was an
inside job that it was the Israeli
Mossad working in concert with the you
know Dick Cheney and Bush and whatever
else but if we continue to have people
believe that the entire climate change
reality is just a hoax then I think that
would that would be hugely damaging in a
thousand years
I just hesitate to say that climate
change is a conspiracy theory in other
words there's fringe elements that deny
it but by and large I don't I just don't
know that that it's even a conspiracy
theory at this point you know
sure sure I I didn't know if I was the
right label to put to it but just in the
sense that some people or a vast amount
of you know us Americans we yeah we're
not me but we tend to think that oh it's
a Chinese hoax or whatever whatever
so yeah I appreciate your answer Minh do
you have one in particular in mind um I
was I was thinking climate change as
well um just because that is the most
beneficial and if we could just kind of
move past this rut that we're in and
start going towards you know a more
eco-friendly approach to our lifestyles
I think that would be probably the best
thing to do yeah I guess a better way to
say it instead of conspiracy is what is
there where if we could get the world
completely united in terms of what we
believe is going on would do the most
good and that's where like listen in the
end if people think Paul McCartney died
40 years ago and was replaced with a
similar-looking left-handed bassist it's
not really gonna make that big of a
difference whether we get agreement on
that or not even if the moon landing was
faked
right like but the climate change one if
we could just get a hundred percent
agreement that this is what's going on I
think it would do the most good
long-term for us absolutely man take my
call thank you appreciate the call we've
been talking about echo chambers that
are created online based on these
recommendation algorithms that exist so
this happens on Facebook this happens on
YouTube this is happening on Instagram
Twitter I'm not sure if they have this
type of algorithm in place but many
places online you were shown videos or
articles or posts that are based on an
algorithm that determines what you are
most likely to engage with based on how
you've reacted to other content what
have you shared what have you spent time
looking at what have you clicked on or
liked or whatever the case may be this
can be problematic because algorithms
can be gamed and algorithms can also
recommend content that for a variety of
different reasons we might not want to
see recommended YouTube is one big place
where this has been really really
controversial and YouTube made an
announcement over the weekend in a blog
post that they're going to stop or at
least reduce recommendations of what
they call quote borderline content and
content that could miss inform users in
harmful ways such as videos promoting a
phony miracle cure for a serious illness
claiming the earth is flat or making
blatant
we false claims about historic events
like 9/11 so the idea here is if we look
at Alex Jones as an example before he
was he was kicked off of YouTube
the idea is there are some very widely
viewed videos for example about Sandy
Hook shooting conspiracy theories and
when it becomes a problem is if people
go on YouTube and they just want
information about the event and they
search for I don't know what happened at
Sandy Hook or something like that they
could get a conspiracy video of Alex
Jones claiming it was a false flag with
paid crisis actors it didn't happen in
the way that supposedly the news tells
us that it happened that's that's an
example what YouTube is saying is not
that they're going to ban the content
itself unless it violates terms and
conditions which is sort of a different
story but what they're saying is they'll
tweak of the algorithm so that if you're
just searching around for information on
some of these topics you're not going to
get conspiracy videos placed in front of
you how much content will this impact
YouTube says that this will impact less
than 1% of all content on YouTube and
again this is not about whether the
content is or isn't allowed that's not
changing the reactions have been pretty
predictable some so-called free speech
absolutists are saying it's censorship
this is an attack on constitutionally
protected free speech and they're saying
all of the things you would anticipate
they would say other people are saying
well hold on a second
YouTube can decide what content it wants
to promote and what content it doesn't
want to promote the recommendation
algorithm is merely how YouTube
expresses what it wants to put a
spotlight on and what it doesn't nothing
illegal is happening here is is this
something that could inadvertently hurt
people who aren't doing anything wrong
sure yeah I mean people spreading
misinformation are going to be hurt by
this and they're going to be at a
disadvantage but people who are also
doing great stuff are going to probably
end up inadvertently caught up in this
as well here's the reality the
recommendation algorithm on YouTube has
always favored some con
and over others it's changing all the
time it's never worked perfectly the
david pakman show YouTube channel has
been hurt by algorithm changes at
different points in time we've had
content that didn't do as well because
of how the algorithm is configured we've
had content that was pushed viral on a
whim that we didn't even understand
because of the algorithm I think that if
we are given the choice between knowing
more about how the algorithm works and
knowing less I prefer to know more
at least they're being upfront about
this tweak what people need to
understand is that either way YouTube is
doing this stuff I'd rather know about
it people can choose not to use YouTube
if they so choose and I am at risk for
sure and people could say but David
aren't you going to change your mind
about this if it ends up hurting you
you're not going to be so lazy and fair
about it it has hurt me at times what
can I do YouTube can have an algorithm
it's ultimately up to me to decide is
being on YouTube at all a net positive
or a net negative and I can decide
whether to keep putting my content there
I'm going to focus my time on making
good content and promoting good ideas if
YouTube becomes too oppressive if my
traffic goes down because of the
algorithm then I'll start looking for
other platforms but the people who are
wanting to have it both ways here saying
that companies should be allowed to do
what they want as long as they're not
breaking the law but at the same time
YouTube's algorithm can't deprioritize
conspiratorial content and sham medical
treatments and all of this other stuff
how can you possibly take both of those
positions doesn't make any sense
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]